so you might know planet bro coaster
it's a series that I fanboys over quite
a few times already but just in case
it's a youtube series by Mike sheets and
masks Bennett in which they play planet
coaster and built this park called
no-name lenio and it's it's one of my
favorite series on planet coaster and
this park is definitely one of my
favorite practice well it's very
realistic
it's very modest and simple in design
but everything is super well thought-out
and the reason that I'm telling you all
of this and I'm showing this is because
I've had the great honor to be a guest
on Planet Bell coaster which meant that
I've appeared on the Los Locos episode
but I'm also adding something to the
park so there will be another episode
with me in it so this is kind of my very
shameless plug of Planet broker sir
seriously it's an amazing series and you
should check out these guys channels and
subscribe to them but also I'm going to
be working on something I'm not going to
be showing everything that I'll be
building but I'll be showing one coaster
station which is a bit of a teaser to
what I'll be showing off in the next
Boat coaster episode so without further
ado let's get into the timeit's and I'll
explain a little bit more along the way
so as you might be able to tell I've
already got a bit of a layout going on
and a small part of a station building
mostly just some messy routes put
together basically the way this works is
that no-name land iya is a bit of an
American park that goes between the
hands of various planets bro coaster
people and they all add some points to
it and I've been given the plug file and
asked to kind of add anything to it and
the best thing I could come up with was
this launched winged liner a coaster now
we'll be showing off more of the coaster
in the actual planet broad coaster video
that's going to come up I don't want to
spoil too much yet and there will also
be some other stuff in there as well but
in this time-lapse I just want to be
show off the build of the station which
is really the big building which we're
getting into in this episode so yeah the
theme in general
stick with what clinic bro poster is all
about it's a series that really delves
into the story and everything behind the
scenes of an actual theme park so it
quite happily goes not just into the
background areas that you see in parks
and really setting up the entire park in
a realistic way but also trying to keep
in mind what kind of times the different
sections of the park would have been
built what kind of money it would take
to build these different sections like
there have been some part where the park
was very low on money at some point in
time and expanded in some cheaper ways
or some sometimes when they didn't
really so much invest in the scenery but
really had to attract some more of the
the thrills for the guests some more of
the teenagers and such which
coincidentally is kind of the parts
where I came in here I came in the
planet bro coaster and the bros kind of
taught me to add something to the park
so that they would have something to
work on again
get some ideas from outside just their
own bubble which is actually something
that works out quite well I find for
myself as well just getting somebody
else to build something in your park no
matter how much different it is from
what you were trying to go for or what
you were trying to plan it always just
kind of works because it throws you off
guard and makes you come up with some
more creative ideas so what I came up
with is a bit of that more slightly more
keep less focused on scenery and entire
immersion but more thrilling kind of
experience which the park tried to get
in here I imagine this expansion would
have been somewhere in the two thousands
and they didn't really put too much
effort into making the entire area one
big themed hole or building rows of
passant with buildings and shops but
instead they're just kind of throwing
all their money into a ridiculous being
them wing run a prototype and theming a
bit of the station and the area around
that but as soon as you actually hop
onto the coaster it's all just going to
be empty grassland
I'll still
try and make that look as nice as I can
but it's really going to be quite simple
in that regard but I didn't want to go
quite all-out with the station and
really just make that the big themed
elements of the ride and the rest of it
of the right speak for itself
so I sprinted the theme that I wanted to
go for it's it's very American inspired
obviously since this is an American park
so that's already a little bit out of my
comfort zone since I usually do a lot of
European things so this this kind of
building is inspired by some National
Park kind of architecture I kind of
based it in terms of scenery and region
on climate I don't know if I actually
pronounced that correctly let me know
because I'm just a Dutch person who
doesn't really know American
pronunciations that well but it's
basically somewhere down the the Rocky
Mountains like still south from that but
still some mountains on the west coast
they were America and it's a little bit
inspired in that sense by vigourously
River Run in Disney or stuff like I
guess grizzly Gulch in this new Hong
Kong which also has kind of similar
theme even if it's a little bit more
Western than that it's really National
Park Mountain Lodge kind of theme so
it's not exactly western it's it's not
really the traditional style of American
architecture which parks really usually
built because it's cheap because it's
just wood but it's it's more of the like
Mountain log cabin or that kind of stuff
that's sort of architecture so I looked
up quite a bit of information on what
mountain homes but also low cabins and
like these ranger stations and stuff
like that look like in the US and that
really served as a basis for how this
building would look like
and also why I'm really building most of
all just these large roofs these large
pointed gabled roofs with all kinds of
wooden beings to support it in some
actually pretty decorative ways there is
quite a bit of detail in this one thing
that was really annoying about the
station though and what made the shape
of the station very bulky is that I
wanted to have this path going over the
station itself and not to throw any
shade to our planet coaster or I guess
it probably I probably do but basically
one of the things that is quite
difficult about winged riders is that
you've got two entrances and two exits
basically one for each side because
you've got a track right in the middle
and you can't really expect people to
walk over that track so you should be
able to enter the station and laser
session on both sides of the train so
you kind of need some kind of walkway
going over or under the station to have
people get to the other side which
planet coaster didn't do it that way
there's just an exit on one side and an
entrance on one side or both on the same
so I kind of made this little man-made
walkway which doesn't really function as
a realistic entrance but I still need to
get that in there to make it look as
though it were actually a realistic
ring- station so hence why we've got
that big walkway in there the only issue
was that it made this fishing quite a
bit more bulky than I was trying to go
for so there's quite a lot of I guess
there's two problems with this building
for one it's on a perfectly square
footprint which already makes it quite
hard to make it look interesting and the
second thing is that we've got that
walkway going over it which means that
it's for one very front heavy because
it's really leaning over the front of
the station and it just means it's going
to be a really tall building with a big
walkway coming straight through the
middle so actually finding out a
composition for this building that would
kind of mitigate those annoying
blockiness
factors I sort of came up with this Lane
and I know Mike taught me to just make
buildings and make them super blocky
because that would make them look
American add something I didn't decide
to do in the end sorry about that but I
really felt this would be a better way
we've kind of got the the front of the
building jutting out like that with the
walkway to create a sort of facade and
it also gives a very nice point to put
the name sign up so it's going to be
it's going to be called Red Hulk so that
will be a perfect place to just put a
big sign saying Red Hawk and just make
that a little bit more spectacular and
it also kind of means that there's a bit
of a front of the building I feel that
you know without that gable jutting
forward and really leaning toward the
path on the front here the building
wouldn't really have too much of a sort
of front facade the rest of the building
is really some roofs in a parallel sort
of fashion to the track with it slightly
raised about the track just so the roof
looks a little bit more uneven an
interesting to look at and then there
are a couple of points where there's
just some stuff jutting out so we've got
a pipe tilting out at the front there to
make that look a little bit more
interesting I was kind of imagining
there could be a shop over there
but alas it's actually too close to the
path above it so I can actually finish
up in there but it still looks pretty
neat I guess and we've got some wooden
beams hanging over the actual front of
the station over the cue line there and
then there's a bunch of weird columns
and roofs throughout the building just
to make everything look a little bit
less square and a bit more like one of
these months in homes basically a lot of
my inspirations including many of these
log cabins and mountain homes they
really have just Gables cetera just
jutting out into every direction many of
them even having very windows things
like that which felt a little bit over
the top but having all kinds of Gables
go into different direction from the
centre of the building that really felt
like something to add into the going and
at that sort of national park flyer to
it well at the same time making it
look a little less boring so that looks
more that's what I'm going for it would
definitely be a case of where a park
through way too much of the scenery
budgets as just those very small parts
of the scenery that you actually see
from apart so everything from the
station to some foliage around the
actual first drop of the coaster it's
very nicely themed and is super detailed
but everything that you're more or less
is kind of see from the coaster itself
is pretty much neglected like they
probably or so I imagine blue and all of
their budgets on just making those small
parts of scenery ridges to be very what
you very often find around parks like
this as you might be able to tell if
you're into coasters a big inspiration
for this costume was Thunderbird at
Holiday Park at Holiday World he I'm
sorry that was actually very bad mistake
at Holiday World in the u.s. in Indiana
if I recall correctly it's basically
inspired by that coaster that was a coin
because it's also a launched winged
rider but it shares a very similar theme
and overall an atmosphere I guess but
also it has that same idea of you know
just being a not so big Park it's not
exactly your Cedar Point or your Disney
tell Cedar Point doesn't even stay in
that well it's not exactly your Disney
or universal or any one of those parks
it's more like a slightly smaller Park
that can afford to build large courses
like this but it's still not the biggest
and most themed park in the world so it
keeps it much more focused and smaller
like this is one I really imagined there
were also a few struggles over here with
trying to get everything to connect to
the path basically here I was trying to
optimize my sight lines for the coaster
so I kind of redid that hill parts every
now and then
since the sight lines here felt really
important because you're kind of okay so
you're walking toward this area walking
over a bridge over the railroad now
actually me keeping
at bridging with connie stupid because
they built the bridge in the first place
at the time when you can have the
railroad intersect with the part which
you now can but regardless the bridge
actually works out quite nicely because
it means your comes on those higher
plane as you walk into the new area and
you're getting from the old Peregrine
inverted coaster area into the wing
Runner area here and exactly from that
plane where you're spending there is
kind of the important inside line of
seeing the the station and then you see
the first drop of the coaster looming in
the background and the placement of the
trope is actually very intended in that
sense I kind of screwed over the plans
for the layout of the park just in favor
of getting the sight lines for this
coaster correct so that might be a very
stupid and ridiculous obsession which I
should probably relax with a little bit
but that's the way it works you walk
over from the bridge you see this
station in the front and behind that you
see the huge first drop and also the
second here on boomin and the same kind
of works from the other side except it
to the other way around
hence why the launch the first drop and
then second hill are really on display
and the rest of the coaster is a little
bit more out back it's a little bit
further away from the past you don't
really see too much of it could probably
see some glimpses of it from the trees
but it's really this part of the layout
that is on display here so we've got
some some interesting foliage going on
here like there's lots of gardening
around here which really has to be
maintained which isn't so much around
the other areas of Clarke this is
actually one of the things that
realistically is something that I always
want to keep in mind since not every
part of the park is very easily reached
by people who have to water the gardens
or is even seen my people at all so
especially if you're going for a
realistic look you want to be quite
selective with where you're actually
putting theming and as Michael so said
in a previous Pro coaster episode green
is cheap but colors are expensive so
your amount of flower usage should be
generally pretty low another issue is
that flowers use
bloom seasonly so you can't really have
blooming flowers entirely all over the
place unless you're constantly replacing
them but that's that's an entirely
different story anyway in any case I
really put some very selected foliage
along the front there for those kind of
practical reasons and similarly I put a
bunch of detail on the station and
that's really just about it that aside
there really isn't too much theming to
this ride and that is also more or less
the station being finished with just a
couple of lamps were pretty much there
and the station is good to go so I would
like to thank you guys very much for
watching this sort of one-off episode of
the row coaster and I hope to see you
guys in the next real episode of Planet
bro coaster in which I'll be sharing all
of my progress which includes quite a
bit more than just in this video with
Mike and with Monica and it and with all
of you guys that's all for me now I'll
see you guys there and have a good day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you
[Music]